can you stop gangbanging for one goddamn
second so I can get to the goddamn door
one of the you and I can know about this
bunny I don't understand why you're just
ignoring me the thrusting of my pelvis
that suggests that maybe you should get
out of my way why are you in my house
[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to three weird games I've
got some games here that are bizarre
maybe good but probably an odd
experience like this first one called
stuck then I am assuming is about
simulating life on a train press Start I
don't have oh we're going breach the
door before the next stop oh wow you you
haven't even told me how oh god I'm the
only colorfully dressed person here
scuse me pardon moi I don't think this
is this is impolite to do no matter who
you are Oh God
I thought this is gonna be a lot easier
than it was oh jeez please excuse me my
wife she's having a baby please somebody
if you could stop humping over in this
general area I'd appreciate it greatly
how how how are you how what the hell is
your baby can you stop gangbanging for
one goddamn second so I can get to the
goddamn door oh goodness
please please please can I please please
you I can't oh that door I didn't know
that door ah you sack of [ __ ] alright
everybody better get the heck e heck out
of my way cuz it's about to get hot and
heavy I'm about to start ripping ass
both you and me and everybody better
clear out of their way if they don't
want any part of that I don't appreciate
the jiggling I really don't appreciate
that jiggle and that's happening on me
you keep that over there with everybody
else do not try to affect me with your
jiggling please can I just I just want
to go by please I just please I need it
so badly
please I left the oven on my entire
houses is burning down I've it's it's
it's the Apple event I gotta order my
phone
my overpriced phone help-help that made
it okay cool great I'm glad was that it
was that Oh number two oh I got a do it
again and it's even more dense and it
was before is that what I'm to
understand about this if you guys could
just cooperate with me like I I know
everybody here probably has social
anxiety but somebody please just look me
in the eye see my incessant urgent need
the thrusting of my pelvis that suggests
that maybe you should get out of my way
oh boy you guys suck greatly oh you suck
get yes okay this should be fun
I should be able to get out now cuz
these guys usually get out of the way
one of those like an end game to this do
you think there's some grand story to
this boa boa bite thank you
let's just carry someone with me I just
pick him up and she's like yeah you're
coming with me now so yeah man this
seems like you know it seems like
something that would go on are oddly
satisfying but somehow it's the exact
opposite of that
can I go can I go can I go it doesn't
seem to be getting any harder either
that or I'm getting better at it
oh there that guy's gonna get cut in
half no my just going for the high score
here excuse me
oh god excuse me should I ask where's
bajo let's quiz Brae is squeezed bow
scores but SQUOZE be oh my god I might
not make this one I magnin oh come on
help
ah [ __ ] what do I get to do that one
again is this really like just is this
honestly an actual objective bass game
is there is there some greater narrative
being woven through this oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy okay here we go
there better be like an end game to this
I don't want to just gone forever yeah
here we go I think they're adding one
more person in every time oh they just
stop looking like people after a while
it just looks like some horrible
horrible horrible horrible horrible race
of penis people no come on please I'm
right there just oh let me worm my way
through yes oh I shoved like 15 people
out of their normal schedules but I may
through there I don't want to keep the
art I'm done with that I got it
just let me die I'm gonna go this way
I'm beating the system I'm going the
wrong way
help help help mom mom you can't even
see me I've won the game
I'm hidden I think it just shrinks down
time every single one too late okay
that's enough of that pretty good I like
it a little a little weird time waster
but then again that sole point of this
right moving on
welcome to my legs got tube now this
game is Oh cutscene it just don't mess
up well you seem like the nervous one
[Music]
[Laughter]
now we just have to fix their legs we
didn't kill them wait did you put that
in the medical box or the tube system
container oh oh oh uh uh um way oh but
how do i oh I can just move with Waze I
thought that was the only way that I can
move with just pulling my arms which
honestly I think would be a much better
game mechanic than oh this horrible
monstrosity that we find ourselves in
okay so yeah we lost our legs hi hello
hi oh good to see you
how did we do now anyway I'll be off you
have a good day
I'll have bad day no legs you know that
you know how it is anyway how do you
could you point me to
my legs might be I don't remember
hmm no hmm
Shh no speaking only you and I can know
about this I am going to find my legs if
it's the last thing I do
but you you stay strong for mother I'll
be back before the moon comes back see
you later friend anyway well if I go get
fit do some push-ups I don't want to fry
your mouse okay
good thing I carried all my weight in my
legs now I don't have to worry about all
that
guardian here uh-huh hello ah a new home
for me here but is it the same without
legs can any man really be a man without
legs or a woman be a woman or anything
be anything without legs I say nay nay
take this with excuse me I forgot this
crap no not that taking this just with
me not taking dish with you [ __ ] you
playing sassy on me huh no not today
oh yeah get out oh well never mind then
um what does that say please do not jump
out of the window you're not my mom Oh
help please nurse hello yep there we go
Hey Hey better skip over there that
could have been dangerous what's down
there hmm
well seems like I'm stuck my bath though
very pugna kind of like a good aroma to
it it's got like a musk coming up
through the bottom of it anyway loose I
can tell any passerby a story if they
want to hear it but until they do I
guess I'm just you know kind of stuck
here huh anyway might as well mellow
about it
yeah starboard let's get out of here
can I open this hope no maybe I can get
all the way up there hope no oh it's not
possible
I've tried it it's not hope buoyant hey
I'm up here now I don't think I was
supposed to be up there if I proclaim
myself from up here nobody would
possibly understand that I don't
actually have legs alright
farewell goodbye hmm I see oh it's so
heavy
nah it's quite heavy I wasn't doing
enough push-ups before oh oh
checkpoint 4 well that's what does
everything look different than it did
before
how does it make any sense hope Oh what
would you loves one do without you get
insured for life lie life insurance
limited time offer includes bonus check
point to ensure that you're still around
when the worst comes oh cool so I can
die oh never mind
oh I get it I only have a limited number
that's not the fourth checkpoints four
checkpoints left oh thank you come I
don't need it I got the control scheme
right here and even though music is
repetitive kind of fun okay not bad it
could be better in a lot of aspects but
you know from a simplicity standpoint
it's pretty good injured me too
I broke my leg last week looking for
someone to rub cream on my leg leg needs
cream and I don't have a wife to do it
buzz Alderson to res attorney at law
please help me with my leg situation wow
you suck an [ __ ]
Mario oh I took way too long with that
one
alright oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what's
going on here well donut it's not a
donut oh yeah rats
hello it's kind of spooky down here I
gotta admit the ambience is feeling
little woo you know what I mean
excuse me excuse me excuse me hello
there like a way up
oh maybe Oh Oh sneaky Oh
ah too sticky now I want to go back oh
let me go back oh come on
Oh where's this oh well that opened up
shh don't tell anybody I'm here all
right
do I need to grab this no apparently not
flip-flop got it nailed it I'm the best
all right I won't if there's something
else over here oh but that's it
no oh god damn it
okay well that was my legs got tube that
was cool that was cool but oh well I
guess I'm done with that I like the
concept the the physical like the the
actual gameplay of it the gameplay
mechanic is really cool it's unique it's
kind of like Octodad but in a 3d sense
2d I guess more like it but it's cool I
like the idea with some work this could
be a really fun game moving on
alright so to end this one off we have a
game called body hiding simulator I'd oh
oh
there's a story hello
I've got a knife um okay I don't see any
bodies so I'm assuming I'm gonna make a
body hello would you like a knife oh you
are horrible oh you're like earthward
and Jim if he got cosmetic surgery to be
more human oh oh uh uh stuff no yeah oh
jeez I do okay
that's horrible um duh hi honey honey
honey
what you know honestly I don't know why
that's great okay that's great okay just
don't go in the back room you know where
is my husband
oh hi hubby what Oh hubby hubby Oh what
is happening in this game have no idea
do I need to murder these people or is
that just what what what do you know why
did you just you just came into my house
you decided to use my bathroom honey
there's a stranger in our house help
honey no oh why are you going back there
there's a stranger upstairs honey honey
upstairs there's a stranger
[Music]
my bad my bad
what bad my bad
did he he was abandoned the law not here
[ __ ] um honey there's a strange man he's
murdered a bunch of people honey look
it's not my fault who are you going
honey believe me help
I mean yes but that doesn't mean you may
you said can you're not even sitting um
honey please strange man no honey honey
honey honey it's just gonna turn into a
big party at my house and I I don't know
why oh there oh oh no there oh no oh no
hey guys listen it's okay just what wait
honey
what husband of mine love of my life oh
okay honey I don't understand why you're
just ignoring me you know this is why
our relationship is falling apart cuz we
just come and you go and I never know
when you're coming and I never when
you're going who are you why are you in
my house please husband of mine help me
for God's sake believe me this is a
problem a very very significant problem
hey honey
listen listen listen listen listen honey
listen honey you don't need to go in
there you don't need to go in there at
all you know in fact you should probably
pack your bags just leave you don't want
to go in there yeah there's nothing to
see there's nothing to do there's
nothing to go anywhere so just go on
your way
let's go for a walk honey let's go for a
walk in the park honey
no wait yeah okay all right well now
I've got a husband loop going on here
but that's not good okay honey listen
listen lesson is turning into an
insurmountable problem that I can't
conquer why I'm suspicious of you that
you're not concerned about what's going
on in here honey you don't need to go in
that room honey no what are you talking
about it's self-defense these weirdos
keep coming to my house when you're not
here I don't know what simulation that
was but I feel horrible for it all these
naked men better than my blue naked
husband but I can't stop murdering them
they're just so damn fragile can I throw
one a easier than another guy no I
didn't work apparently hey does this
bother you at all who's bothered to you
that this guy's naked muscles are better
than yours look I don't know how many
people are taking a dump upstairs oh hi
forgot about you um you like pottery all
right well you don't need to be that
insulting about it you come up here you
look like you need to take a dump all
right what's the state of my bathroom
you guys um you guys uh guys all right
in here
burgers weren't gem earthworm James well
here's a toothbrush weird double
toothbrush I didn't kill you trashcan
apparently not you though you're tough
you're strong hey you're coming with me
hey well you and I take a little soirée
into the bedroom sorry Vera I'm drunk
already
yeah Clark I'm hit oh I get it you can't
stop staring at that guy's took us me
neither
let's uh plop you guys over here you
might want to censor this next part it's
gonna get very erotic
oh gosh when will my husband come home I
just own
hello strangers how are oh [ __ ] well
[ __ ] god damn it okay that was body
hiding simulator axe and only press the
reset button
absolutely accidentally um weird very
weird it raises a lot of questions that
I don't have the answer to but that's
what life's all about
so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you first some reason want
to play any of these weird games I'll
provide links in the description below
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]